thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode hey crazies what if we dug
a hole all the way through the earth how
long do you think it would take someone
to fall all the way through about 40
minutes that's it just 40 minutes and it
doesn't even matter how you dig the hole
this tunnel takes 40 minutes that tunnel
takes 40 minutes all the tunnels take 40
minutes but what did I get that number
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon unless
you're making really sensitive
measurements or you're near a neutron
star or a black hole
gravity is accurately described by
Newton's laws but even that can be
challenging if you try to solve this
problem as is you're gonna run into
trouble
see we're used to gravity or weight
being pretty constant myclone has a
weight that's pulling him toward the
ground but that weight is the same up
here or down here or over here if he
falls that weight stays the same it's
constant unfortunately most people have
spent their entire lives near the
surface of the earth and that's created
a bit of a bias Michael owns weight
might be 165 pounds on the ground but
it's a hundred and forty pounds in an
average low-earth orbit an effectively
zero in deep space weight is actually
different depending on where you are
weight is just another word for the
force of gravity it depends on how far
apart things are it's just that the
earth is so big and so massive that we
don't notice the differences at least
when we're near it Mike loans weight is
only approximately constant if we drop
him from low Earth orbit we'll have to
be a little more careful in a case like
that
we have to consider how far the clone is
from the earth when a force changes with
position even Newton's laws can be
notoriously difficult to solve we tend
to get nonlinear differential equations
like this one and that's assuming the
earth doesn't move which is only
approximately true
seriously I spent like four hours trying
to solve that thing symbolically before
I gave up but a computer can give us an
answer as long as we plug in specific
numbers assuming no air resistance it
takes myclone six point three minutes to
reach the ground if you assume a
constant wait you get five point eight
minutes which is clearly wrong the math
gets even harder when both objects are
allowed to move it's called the two-body
problem where body is just another word
for object although if we're using
clothes body is a fine word let's say I
put two of my clones in the middle of
deep space about five feet apart they'll
each have a force of gravity toward the
other both of them have mass about 75
kilograms worth so they will attract
each other how long will it take that
gravity to bring them together not as
long as you might think the computer
says about 5.8 hours which is apparently
just enough time for them to run out of
oxygen
the thing is though using a computer is
kind of a brute-force method if there's
nothing particularly elegant about it
it'll work on just about anything orbits
balls on ramps single pendulums double
pendulums masses on Springs it'll even
work on many body problems as long as
you've got the processing power boring
we want a solution that's a little more
elegant something outside the box in
physics sometimes it's helpful to
imagine a challenging problem is a
completely different problem consider
our two clones again they might be
falling toward each other but let's
imagine for a minute that they aren't
let's imagine that they're orbiting a
common center of mass instead believe it
or not orbits are way easier to solve
than freefall paths these elliptical
orbits obey very simple patterns we know
each clone will be opposite each other
at all times
we know the farther they are from each
other the slower they'll loop and
vice-versa we know their common center
of mass will be a focus of both ellipses
and the foci of an ellipse are always on
its major axis half of that major axis
is called the semi-major axis typically
labeled a
we also know their motion is periodic my
clothes will always return to their
original starting places after a certain
amount of time that time is called the
period and is given by this simple
equation if we know the semi-major axis
of each Clones path and we know the mass
of each clone we can find their orbital
period what does that have to do with
falling though everything in orbit is
the same as falling the International
Space Station is falling toward the
earth it's just moving so fast sideways
that it continuously misses the earth
curves away from it as it falls it's the
same with my clothes
they're also falling toward each other
they're just moving so fast sideways
that they miss but what if they didn't
miss what if the ellipses were so long
and skinny that the clones ran into each
other somewhere that would happen around
here when they're closest to their
center of mass if we make the ellipses
really skinny this is pretty much a free
fall problem actually it's exactly a
free fall problem in fact we already
know how to find the time the sum of the
semi-major axes is just half the
distance between them this equation
tells us the period is 11.6 hours but
the clones run into each other about
halfway through their orbital cycle or
after half the period that's 5.8 hours
exactly what the computer got earlier
bingo bango this trick will work for any
freefall problem want to know how long
it would take for the moon to fall into
the earth the sum of the semi-major axes
is just half the distance to the moon
the time 4.8 days
did you drill a hole all the way through
the earth and fall in the sum of the
semi-major axes is just half the
distance across the earth otherwise
known as the radius of the earth the
time 42 minutes of course that last one
is assuming the earth is perfectly
uniform which it isn't Henry from
minutephysics went through the trouble
and one of his videos if you're
interested spoiler alert it's still
around 40 minutes there's another aspect
of this tunnel that I happen to find a
little more interesting see gravity
doesn't magically come from the center
of the earth if we're outside the earth
we can
pretend like it does we imagine the
earth as a tiny point mass and then
measure everything from there
in reality though a separate gravity
comes from every tiny particle that
makes up the earth remember everything
with mass attracts everything else with
mass at all times a falling person is
being attracted toward every particle in
the earth when they're outside the earth
all those particles are underneath them
but once they're inside some of those
particles are above them some of the
earth is pulling them upward which makes
them lighter you weigh less underground
your weight only depends on the part of
the earth that's closer to the center
than you let's say one of my clones is
in a deep hole his weight comes from the
mass inside this sphere these other two
sections of the earth
cancel each other's effects the part
above him pulls him up just as much as
this part pulls him down and that's true
no matter how deep the hole is if
there's a tunnel all the way through the
earth and my clone falls into it it's as
if the earth is getting less massive as
he falls he would still speed up as
expected but his weight would decrease
on the way down as he passes through the
core his weight would go to zero he
would be weightless after that the
weight changes direction which will slow
him down
eventually he'll come gently to rest at
the other end and as we said before the
whole trip takes about 40 minutes but
but what happens if we don't catch him
he'll fall back down again eventually
he'll reach his original starting point
another 40 ish minutes later if we never
catch him he starts to look like a block
bouncing on a spring it's the same
motion I don't mean kind of the same I
mean exactly the same the forces that
govern both motions are some constant
stuff times a distance so it's only
natural that their motions would be the
same we could have imagined this tunnel
problem as a spring problem instead and
42 minutes would still have been our
answer reimagining is like the ultimate
physics trick but the coolest thing
about this is that it doesn't even
matter where the hole goes when we write
the equation like this it makes it seem
like you have to travel the entire
diameter of the year
but all that matters here is the density
of the earth we can drill a hole
wherever we want the math will always
predict a 42 minute travel time actually
if the tone doesn't go directly between
the poles you have to consider the
rotation of the earth dude
why do you got to be such a buzzkill all
the time he's right
since the earth is spinning the Coriolis
force would have to be factored in for
most tunnels unfortunately we can't
drill a tunnel between the poles
creating a tunnel like this requires
there be land on both sides of the earth
but there's no land at the North Pole we
live on a planet that's mostly covered
in water fun fact if you take a map of
the earth and superimpose it on the same
map rotated 180 degrees you'll see all
the places you can make an earth
sandwich because no one wants soggy
bread on their sandwich am i right so
what's the crazy physics trick that
makes gravity easy it's the ability to
imagine one type of problem as a
completely different problem it is your
problem instead of a direct
gravitational attraction imagine
gravitational orbits and then just make
the orbits very eccentric and take half
the period instead of a person falling
through an earth tunnel imagine they're
bouncing on a spring and take half the
period it's the easiest way to calculate
travel times and gravitational systems
so are you an out-of-the-box thinker let
us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
if you're naturally curious or want to
build your problem-solving skills then
get brilliant premium to learn something
new every day
brilliant has over 60 interactive
courses in math science and computer
science if you liked this video you
might like their course on gravitational
physics where you can learn all about
Newtonian gravity when you're ready try
their quiz that walks you through the
two-body problem or the quiz on
gravitational pendulums
which should look familiar if you're
finding them a bit challenging
you can always brush up on the math with
their new interactive calculus course
where visual and physical intuition is
used to present the major pillars of
calculus
brilliant puzzles you surprises you and
expands your understanding of the modern
world if this sounds like a service
you'd like to use go to brilliant org
slash science asylum today the first 200
subscribers will get 20% off an annual
subscription the Sun uses quantum
tunneling for nuclear fusion and nuclear
fusion is how the Sun creates light so
is this the light at the end of the
tunnel you've won my comments section
today master theory on it nice one into
everyone else thanks for watching